today on the matt walsh show joe biden
has proposed a nationwide mask mandate
this idea is very stupid on a number of
levels and we'll dissect each of those
levels today also five headlines
including a wave of depression and
suicide
uh due in part to the coronavirus
lockdowns we'll discuss that and the new
york post reports on something called
erotic weight gaining which is a thing
now apparently and
of course we have to talk about it
finally in our daily cancellation i will
cancel
human rights i have my reasons i'll
explain them
all of that on the way but we start here
the newly formed biden harris team has
presented their first
federal mandate proposal a preview of
things to come should this ticket win
democrats love nothing more than
federal mandates um provided of course
that they're the ones in charge of the
federal government
if they aren't then naturally actions
taken by the federal government are
literally fascist literally tyrannical
literally what literal nazis would
literally do
in any case their mandated proposal is a
nationwide
mask requirement everyone in the country
all 330 million people
must wear masks outside uh all over the
place so if you live in like north
dakota
with a population density of
approximately half a person per 50
square miles
you must wear a mask to walk down the
street that's that's the idea
and here they are explaining their idea
in more detail
this is not about democrat republican or
independent
it's about saving americans lives so
let's institute
a mass mandate nationwide starting
immediately
and we will save lives the estimate is
r will save over 40 000 lives
in the next three months if that is done
now let me turn it over to my colleague
and running mate
she has a few comments to make thanks
joe
that's what real leadership looks like
we just witnessed real leadership
which is joe biden said that as a nation
we should all be wearing a mask for the
next
three months because it will save lives
and the thing about joe that the
american people know
is that his role of leadership in our
country has always been about doing
what's best for the people of our
country and it's also been about racism
right isn't that what you said
kamala you it's about what it's doing
what's best but also racism i mean you
definitely said the racism part he's
racist you said that that was part of it
only just a few months ago you said that
anyway putting that aside somehow
they are they are saying three months
everyone wears a mask
if you're a farmer in nebraska wear a
mask while you milk your cows if you're
hiking the appalachian trail through
west virginia
wear a mask wouldn't want to infect a
deer or i don't know a tree
now there are a few issues here um the
first is a simple fact
rather perhaps irrelevant these days
that the federal government doesn't have
the authority to require that 330
million people
wear a certain article of clothing or a
certain accessory
um i understand we're way past the point
of worrying about silly little things
like constitutional authority
but even so i just want to note for the
record the federal government doesn't
have it
in this case um
second point the efficacy of masks
is far from settled science despite what
what the way it's presented in the media
the new england journal of medicine for
example an article published in may
says this in part and this again was in
may so not all that long ago it says
we know that wearing a mask outside
health care facilities offers little if
any protection from infection
public health authorities define a
significant exposure to cover 19
has face-to-face contact within six feet
with a patient with with symptomatic
covet 19 that is sustained for at least
a few minutes and some say more than 10
minutes or even 30 minutes
the chance of catching cover 19 from a
passing interaction in a public space is
therefore minimal
in many cases the desire for widespread
masking is a reflexive reaction
to anxiety over the pandemic end quote
and i think the other fact you have to
take into account here is
even if you succeed in getting everyone
to wear masks which you won't
but if you do what you certainly will
never succeed in doing is getting
getting everyone to practice good mask
hygiene the cdc says
if you have a cloth cloth mask which
most people do and we've been told not
to wear the surgical masks anyway to
save them for
healthcare providers then you should be
washing it in hot water in your washer
or with bleach by hand
after each use how many people are doing
that
i have no idea but it ain't everyone or
even close to everyone i'm sure of that
so
by requiring everyone to wear masks the
reality is that a certain large
preponderance of people
will be walking around with dirty german
spittle soaked pieces of cloth
affixed to their faces how healthy is
that
see all of all of the studies on masks
seem to
assume that you're properly wearing a
clean masks
mask well what about a dirty one which
is what millions of americans are
wearing and will wear no matter what
that's just the reality and our policies
have to deal with
and in reality third point and here's
uh i think a basic argument or
observation that those
in support of these mask measures cannot
answer and haven't even really
tried to answer if masks would save
whatever 40
000 lives or whatever probably arbitrary
figure biden gave us there
it would save that many and it would
save that money in three months he says
then
how many lives could we have saved if
we'd had a nationwide mass mandate for
the last 10 years or 20 or however long
to protect against the flu and other
illnesses yes covet has a higher
mortality rate than the flu yes but
you can't deny if masks could save
thousands of lives from covid then
they would also save thousands from the
flu wouldn't they and a life is a life
isn't it
this is about saving lives didn't you
say so why didn't anyone anywhere ever
at any point
even mention the idea of a mass mandate
to save lives during flu season
literally
thousands could have been saved why
wasn't it ever suggested
why i mean let's use some hard numbers
to frame this arbitrary yes but so is
the 40 000 figure i suspect so
let's say just for the sake of argument
that a masked mandate over the last
three years would have saved 40 000
lives from the flu and
another 10 000 from various other
illnesses spread through coughing
sneezing talking et cetera so
let's say it's 50 000 lives three years
it seems like a very conservative
estimate if biden is telling us 40 000
can be saved in three months from covid
so again let's let's just say it's 50
000 lives over three years
if you're using the it's worth it to
save one life argument for a mask
mandate
um would that three years of a mass
mandate had been worth it to save a life
in fact 50 000 lives let's say
if it wouldn't be worth it then why is
it worth it now and if it would be worth
it then why didn't you ever suggest it
and whatever your reason for not
proposing a mass mandate before and thus
tacitly supporting the deaths of so many
people by your logic
why don't you propose a permanent mask
mandate going forward
because whatever time period you suggest
for the mask mandate
three months six months whatever it is
um what happens when that period is up
let's
you know let's say we have a mass
mandate for six months okay
180 days what happens on day 181 are
lives not worth saving anymore
save lives for 180 days but not 181 days
see this doesn't make sense now i
personally don't care that much if
people want to wear masks or if
individual stores want to choose to
require it their property their
business their choice but a mask mandate
especially a federal mask mandate
is absurd arbitrary onerous
and almost certainly unconstitutional
and that's the point now let's get to
our five headlines
before we talk news here uh i got to
tell you about our very good friends at
rock auto you know the last thing
anybody wants to do
right now is spend hours at an auto
parts store last thing anyone wants to
do
anytime is spend hours on an auto parts
store or frankly any other kind of store
it's so much easier to just go to
rockauto.com you know it's better to do
that than to walk into the store
go through the whole rigmarole answer
all the questions then just go online
they order the
part anyway you could have done that
yourself go to rockauto.com you've got
it at your desk you've got it at your in
in your pocket that you carry around
your phone rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airline
airlines do um why spend you know twice
as much for the same parts uh why spend
twice as much
for a smaller selection there's an even
better
question walk.rockauto.com is a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
rockauto.com catalog is unique very easy
to navigate
and you can quickly see all the parts
available for your car truck go to
rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
truck right walsh in there how did you
hear about this box so that they know
that
we sent you okay number one journalists
today journalists today are
celebrating another journalist who
asked a question it's it's a little bit
of scare quote overlord here
overload but uh basically this it's all
bullcrap is what i'm saying but
he asked a question and is being hailed
and celebrated for
uh this question listen to it here
after three and a half years you
regretted all all the lying you've done
to the american people
all the lying all the dishonesties that
who has done
you have done uh tensorflow go ahead
please
please go ahead
i wanted to ask about payroll tax so
what we have here is what we've seen
for uh especially during the trump now
it's been this way for for
decades really but especially during the
trump era this is
journalism as performance
uh it's not journalism at all it's just
it's a performance he's he's performing
for the camera
what other point would there be to that
question what well you know
you're asking the president united
states a question you're in a press
conference
um this is this is supposed to be a
service that you're providing for the
people so that we can get answers and
that sort of thing
kind of answer what kind of answer do
you think you're going to get from that
no what he was hoping for in fact this
was just antagonism
uh this was he was hoping for some kind
of
angry response from trump and then he
could mix it up and uh
try to embarrass trump and at the same
time elevate himself of course that's
what this is all about
but uh that's you know i didn't go to
journalism school but
admittedly but i i don't think that's
what journalism is actually supposed to
be number two
david blaine is back the magician
performance artist uh i guess that's
what we call him he's got a new stunt
planned
big deal hasn't done anything in 10
years okay what has he cooked up for us
now a decade later he's been working on
this we're told for a decade
what is it he had well what he's going
to do is he's going to hold on to some
balloons
and float really high that's the plan
here's the the preview
[Music]
[Music]
all right i doesn't strike you as a bit
egotistical to call this stunt the
ascension
but you know the real problem is is that
a guy already did this
remember there was that guy that tied
balloons to his lawn chair and floated
up to like mars or something i believe
if i remember correctly
uh in fact multiple people have done
this they made a they made a pixar movie
about this in fact
which is based on a true story so this
is this just i to me this is
disappointing 10 years and this is what
you come up with
i'm going to hold a balloon and float
cool i you know i would love to do that
too but i just don't know if it quite is
worth the hype
um number three reading from the daily
wire says
more than 25 percent of uh young
americans age 18 to 24 have seriously
considered killing themselves during the
last month according to the morbidity
and mortality weekly report released on
thursday by the centers for disease
control and prevention
uh says the coronavirus disease 2019
pandemic has been associated with mental
health challenges related to the
morbidity and mortality caused by the
disease and to mitigation activities
including the impact of physical
distancing and state home orders
um symptoms of anxiety disorder and
depressive disorder increased
considerably in the united states during
april june of 2020 compared with the
same period in 2019
now this is many of us warned that this
was going to happen
you're not only taking away people's
jobs and livelihood you're isolating
them
keeping them shut away from contact with
other people
and so of course you're gonna have now
especially for someone who's already
dealing with
depression dealing with uh anxiety
mental illness whatever it is
shutting them away and on top of that
you're also bombarding them every single
day with uh with you're gonna die
it's a disaster it's the end of the
world type of stuff so it's just
it it's not surprising it's tragic and
horrible it's not surprising that would
have this effect remember
trump brought this up months ago and
again our truth-seeking truth
uh finding journalists in the media
mocked him for it and fact-checked him
trump brought up months ago
that this is going to lead to suicide
and depression then we got all the
fact check oh no it isn't they said well
here we are
although i do think we should also note
it because it's important that
you know and this is this is one of the
reasons why
um the
the the lockdowns and the effect on
mental health has been so bad is because
we we already live in a culture
that is very depressed and much more
suicidal
than at other points in history and it's
a problem that goes
down into very young ages um
so this is this is this is part of a
cultural trend a long long-standing
cultural trend
which isn't to downplay but precisely
the opposite to say that this
we've got a a serious problem and even
when we get past the lockdown insanity
they're still going to be this problem
um and we could talk about you know
dissecting this and
but but one of the one of the
i think fundamental things feeding it is
that we live in a culture
um that is at its core quite empty and
people have
no sense of purpose no sense of any
greater
reason for existence
it's a very nihilistic culture and so
that's what
is going to lead in part to this as well
number four brett favre speaking to usa
today
shows us shows us what courage truly
looks like this is brett favre
he says um and he was asked about the
kneeling issue says
i know from being in an nfl nfl locker
room for 20 years regardless of race
background money you grew up with
we were all brothers it didn't matter
guys got along great
will that be the same with the kneeling
scenario i don't know if one guy chooses
to stand for his cause another guy
chooses to kneel for his cause is one
right and the other wrong
i don't believe so we tend to be fixed
on highs
i don't know what it's like to be black
it's not for me to say what's right and
what's wrong
i don't know we should all be true i
know we should i do know we should all
be treated equal
if you can't do that you shouldn't be in
america there's no right answer other
than that the right answer is
that we all get along it seems like the
more people try
the more damage is done this is you know
yeah
what what a courageous answer from
bradford but all these all these
athletes are proving they may be
physically tough
but uh when it comes to moral courage
there's a real deficiency there
your answer is well then there's no
right there's no wrong
here's all i'll say we should all get
along
that's i'll take a stand and say we
should be getting along
great insight from brett favre number
five here's something
that i just found out existed um proving
the old adage that ignorance is bliss
erotic weight gaining is a thing
unfortunately the new york post reports
on the important story of a guy named
brian nicknamed
gaynor bull who has intentionally gained
over 300 pound
pounds he eats 10 000 calories a day one
meal for him is like three combo meals
five or six sides now has a stomach the
size of a small asteroid
and again all of this is on purpose uh
some kind of like fetish and he
apparently has legions of fans who watch
him eat
and just enjoy gazing upon his bulbous
physique one fan on instagram for
example left a comment saying you are
one perfect inflating huge handsome bear
by the way the words inflating and
handsome
really don't go together but but
here's my point um do i have a point
i think i do the point is that the
internet should be destroyed uh it is a
cancer it is a virus
um and this is this is part of the
problem
this guy brian clearly mentally ill
his fans clearly mentally ill
uh and and mentally ill people have
always existed presumably fat fetishists
have always existed in some capacity but
now with the internet people like this
are are able to congregate they're able
to form communities
where they encourage each other in their
perversion and their degeneracy
and that's maybe the worst thing about
the internet there's a lot of
competition for that title but
perhaps the worst thing is what it has
done to the concept of
community because it used to be that
your community
was the neighborhood where you live uh
or or you form a community
as a church or around some other sort of
solid healthy thing real world
thing now a community just becomes a
collection of people who enjoy
the same thing and often the thing they
enjoy is repulsive and self-destructive
and bizarre
so there's no edification there's no
growth well there is growth just not
not emotional and spiritual growth is
what i'm talking about there's nothing
nothing positive to come
of of the community other than this
mutual encouragement
to continue being weirdos and that's
most of the community on the internet
that's really what it is
just a bunch of weirdos getting together
and encouraging each other and telling
each other that they're not really
weirdos
um you know it's it's someone has some
some freaky gross thing they're into
they can just google it
and boom they find a whole collection of
other lunatics just like them
whereas in the past before the internet
you know they would have hidden that
part of themselves
in shame as they should maybe seek
counseling for it either of those
options are
better than what we have now um and it's
because now you can
you can you know it's certainly
preferable to or preferable to going on
instagram and getting your kicks by
watching a morbidly obese man eat a
burrito which is what's
where we are now and by the way this
cheapening of the idea of community
it doesn't just apply to this fetish
type of stuff
i mean i think it applies even to you
know people that say they're in a
community because they all like the
movie star wars or something
like that um or you know communities of
people that play video games
there's nothing wrong with playing video
games or liking star wars that's not
really a community though that's just
you enjoy the same thing great that
shouldn't be a community because there's
no other there's no
shared value system there um the only
shared experience is just this
recreational thing you like doing
uh it's not really what a community is
supposed to be and
we we as humans do need community
but we're finding we are we are uh
fulfilling that need in these kinds of
communities around some
one little thing that we like even if
it's a perfectly fine
thing rather than fulfilling that need
through a real
real life um
you know community all right let's
let's go to our daily cancellation today
for our daily cancellation i will be
canceling human rights
uh no more human rights so you don't you
don't get human rights anymore they're
canceled that's not exactly the point
i'm not canceling human rights per se as
much as i'm canceling
human rights as the foundation of our
moral and political arguments especially
as conservatives
i'm going to suggest that when we're
making arguments advocating our position
we should be grounding our argument in
something other than this incessant
appeal to human rights
to sort of set things up here i want to
go back to biden at that press
conference yesterday to something else
that biden said while pitching his plan
to muzzle the country with masks
i didn't play this earlier um but but
this was this this was something else he
said during that press conference that i
thought was interesting listen to this
today i want to talk about one thing
very straightforward doesn't have
anything to do with
democrats republicans or independents
it has to do with a single simple
proposition
every single american should
be wearing a mask when they're outside
for the next three months at a minimum
every governor should mandate
every governor should mandate mandatory
mask wearing the estimates by the
experts are
will save over 40 000
lives in the next three months
40 000 lives that people act responsibly
and uh it's not about your rights it's
about your responsibilities
as an american it's not about your
rights it's about your responsibility
it's a rather extraordinary thing for a
presidential candidate to say especially
one on the left
now some on the right some conservatives
are acting quite scandalized and
outraged by this comment from biden
um but i'd like for us to rather than
putting our hands up against our
foreheads and fainting like victorian
women over this comment i'd like for us
to stop and really think
about what's being said here i obviously
disagree with the
mask mandate idea and so i disagree that
it's our responsibility to all wear
masks all the time everywhere but
i i appreciate the framing and i think
this is a good strategy by biden to flip
this
rights thing around and focus on the
other r word which is responsibility
and this is exactly what conservatives
should be doing
not about masks but in general in the
battle of ideas we should be making
responsibility much more the foundation
the centerpiece
of our political uh and moral arguments
rather than constantly going on about
rights because that's all all it ever is
now is we're talking about our rights
the problem with human rights is that
it's an incredibly
vague concept there's no agreed upon
definition of it
and i suspect that the vast majority of
people even on the right
who talk about their rights couldn't
offer
any definition if you ask them at least
not a coherent one
now a conservative will will tend to
give a definition like this
this is this is usually about the best
you could hope for they'll say they'll
say rights are inalienable and endowed
by the creator
okay i agree i agree with the founding
fathers on that but that's not a
definition that doesn't tell me
what sorts of things actually are rights
that's a description of the source of
rights not a definition of the term
itself it's like if i asked you
to define the word flower and you said
well they're pretty and they grow
they grow out of the ground that's an
accurate description yes but it's not a
definition it doesn't tell me what a
flower is
it gives me part of the picture but if
that's all i know about flowers then i'm
liable to walk through a forest
and think that everything i see is a
flower
a similar problem with human rights um
we as a society
are walking through the proverbial
forest and thinking everything we see
is a human right i mean we think that
human rights literally grow on trees it
seems like
rights are inalienable and endowed by
the creator okay
then is housing a right what about
college if you say no
how do you know they aren't rights and
don't tell me they aren't outlining the
bill of rights so what the bill of
rights was never supposed to be a
comprehensive list of every right that
belongs to man
don't tell me the creator hasn't endowed
us with that right or you know a right
to free housing
um or something like that how do you
know did you ask him
don't tell me it isn't in the bible
first of all our laws aren't based on
the bible
specifically because this isn't a
theocracy second there's very little in
the bible that could be construed as an
endorsement of say
free speech rights or due process rights
so
how do you know those are rights and
someone some of some of the leftist
right claims aren't valid what is a
right
this is the problem and i firmly believe
that all of the strife and disagreement
in modern society springs at least
partially from this dynamic that we all
are always and everywhere
talking about our rights yet almost none
of us can give a coherent definition of
the term
and even if we can it will be impossible
to get
even just the preponderance of people to
agree with it
what about responsibility admittedly
you'll never get everyone to agree on
what our responsibilities are or how to
define the term but
i'm not suggesting that we can ever get
universal agreement on anything
what i'm suggesting is that the concept
of human rights is especially obscure
and and thus not a great foundation for
an argument a position
or even a philosophy
responsibility is a little better
we can all define it you know a
responsibility or duty is a simply a
moral or legal obligation
according to webster it's an uh
obligatory task conduct service or
function that arises from one's position
now again not saying we've erased all
ambiguity here i'm saying that
we're on firmer and more definable
ground than we were before with rights
i think wherever possible we should be
making our case arguing for a particular
thing
by framing it in these terms joe biden
says that
um arising from our position as
americans we have a moral obligation to
wear a mask to protect other people
i don't agree but that's that's a strong
argument actually and probably
persuasive to a lot of people
so let me give you an example of how
this could work if conservatives were to
use the same tech
uh abortion generally what we say
is that an unborn child has a right to
life and i agree that the child does but
we run into this problem what is a right
how do you know that he has a right to
life what are you talking about and
uh are you saying that the right to life
is universal and immutable
what death row inmates what about
someone who breaks into your home what
about enemy combatants
on the battlefield do they have a right
to life
um there are ways to meet these
rejoinders but you see how we're already
lost in the weeds
and in fact we have to admit that well
no your right to life is not in fact
immutable you can
in effect lose it or forfeit it just
like any other right can be lost or
forfeit you don't have a second
amendment right
in prison for example so you see how
opaque
this has all become and how far away we
are now
from the point we are just lost out
way in the weeds out there what if we
try a different approach
the other r word what if we argue very
simply
that a parent has a responsibility to
their child
arising from their position as a parent
and from the special relationship
between parent and child a parent has a
responsibility
to provide for and care for their child
or to find someone else who can
this is a lot more solid and everyone
everyone agrees with it actually to a
large extent everyone agrees
that the parent of a five-year-old who
leaves a child alone all weekend to go
party
should go to jail why because she has a
responsibility to that child
um but but why is it that she can't go
to a party and leave her kid alone but
her neighbor jim can
see if the child is left alone the
mother is arrested not the neighbor jim
why is that well because
unless jim was specifically hired to
care for the child he has
almost no responsibility to the child
the mother has almost
all of the responsibility to the child
we all agree on this
i've never heard anyone advocate the
revocation of child neglect and abuse
laws
so all we're doing now as pro-lifers is
making the rather logical and reasonable
point
that the parental responsibility we all
agree with and see
and acknowledge starts in the womb
that's all and the really interesting
interesting thing is that
the responsibility argument completely
neutralizes the bodily autonomy argument
from the left
when you make the right to life argument
then it becomes a competition between
the child's right to life and the
mother's right to autonomy
i suggest that we step out of that back
and forth entirely and make this not
about anyone's rights
but about their responsibility a woman
has a right to her body sure but she
also has a responsibility to her child
it's that simple most debates can be
framed this way
i would say even gun rights can become
gun responsibility it's not so much that
i have a right to a gun for myself but
that i have a responsibility to protect
my family and my community
and i may need a gun to do that
especially these days i think that
framing
in these times in particular is is more
persuasive
and it goes in the other direction okay
you say you have a right to have your
college
debt paid for okay well i don't have a
responsibility to do that
i don't have a responsibility to do that
for you see rather than making
vague claims about your rights what
you're really what you really need to
explain
is why i have a responsibility to pay
for your college
that's going to be much more difficult
case to make
we're so conditioned in this country to
think always about our rights
talk about our rights scream about our
rights rarely do we even think about
responsibility about duty
about what our obligations are as
parents as people as americans
um aside from the ambiguity of human
rights and all the problems i've already
outlined
the other issue is that this obsessive
focus on rights at the expense of
responsibility has helped to turn us
into a bunch of self-entitled whiny
children
only ever thinking about what we are
owed and never about what we owe
there's quite a lot of focus on what
other people owe especially what other
people owe
us certainly those rich people those
privileged etc and so
forth they owe us so much they owe they
owe what about you
what do you owe what are your duties
what are you what are you obliged to do
and this is how we should think and how
we should encourage others to think
and how we should present our arguments
and so
for now human rights are canceled
at least we have to stop talking about
them talk about responsibility instead
that's going to do it for this week
everybody have a great weekend
uh godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
we'll tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there